[Music]
Ugh
Hello, everyone from JS Comp Korea. This time, I am
Noh Ji-yeon, and I am in charge of presenting the JavaScript content that I created as I wanted to create a wallpaper. Then, I will
begin the presentation.
My presentation will proceed like this. First of all, before I start the presentation, I  Uh, I'll
start by first talking about the motivation for starting a personal project. I
'll introduce myself.
Hello, the presenter is a developer. I'm not a cancer patient.
I also do it.
When I first started working, I worked at a financial development
company. Now, I'm working on a financial development project.  After seeing this, I wanted to get more excited about development, so I
developed Node JS at a startup.
Then, I got so good at JavaScript that I
wrote a book using JavaScript. I had a relationship with a high school manufacturer, so I wrote the book as a co-author.  I've
written this before,
and currently I'm at Kakao Bank.
I'm a software engineer who implements visualizations on the Kakao Make BI platform.
In fact, working at a company is fun and makes a living, but I also have a separate
main job that gives me spiritual fulfillment.
That's BTS Cancer.  This is my main job. I
put it like that at work, and I'm gaining my mental balance.
Then, I thought, how can I make this more fun? I
combined JavaScript, which I liked, with BTS, and what I do, implementing Sig Car.  I wanted to try it with fear once more,
and now I was looking for an idea of ​​what to do with my personal project that started with more law. I would like to
tell you about the song Tomorrow in the winter of 2017, when I first started liking BTS.
I wrote the lyrics for Tomorrow Head.  There was a time when I was comforted and empathized through the contents of
5. So I was curious as to whether people with other cancers would also receive comfort from the lyrics.
So I looked on Twitter. I am
receiving comfort from the lyrics. I am feeling a bit frustrated these days through the lyrics.  I
was able to see a tweet on Twitter that said Jinshin was close to second place in the lyrics.
Then, why was it comforted by the lyrics?
10,000 yen I was curious once more.
So my personal project is to
look into what is in the lyrics based on this data.  For the purpose of doing so,
my lover's project started early.
First, my project progress goes like this. First, I
selected a topic through SNS or thesis articles as before, and I went through a
preprocessing process to have an indispensable design, which was called data work.  We will
conduct the analysis through sql or keyword exposure, and then implement each of the D3 Roshi. I
will give you the 5-detailed purse difference.
Then, at this time, I will talk about the process in earnest.
Do you remember the topic I talked about earlier
in the lyrics?  As to why it was given number 1, I got it by empathizing with the interpretation.
And what I mean by sympathy is whether the singers themselves conveyed it directly or through their own
stories, and through the sincerity of the song, they felt that the fans would empathize with them,
and many different people.  Each of these 5 people
have personal stories, and since there are various stories that can resonate with those stories, I wonder if they will
find comfort through such empathy, or because they have a wide emotional spectrum, there
will be a lot of sections where people can feel empathy.
Through this thought, through this, I took three points,
5 and
within these three four links, I derived twelve indicators,
and now, finally, through Leroy's twelve indicators or more additional
thoughts of mine,
uh, what I initially thought of.  I
thought that I might be able to prove the topic or find out new discoveries that I didn't know about through the data.
So now, I'll design the data. The
data needed for the indicator I mentioned earlier was like this.
Album 0 list lyrics and composition lyricist information  Now,
this is a storage space, post, sql, and I designed a table to store it in.
After that, I also conducted research, and there was an API for Naver Vibe, and I
retrieved the necessary data from here.
Here, I created the script using Noru js.
All of the after-sales data collection was done by me, and I brought data from BT's EXO. I
'll talk about why I used groups from all over the world later.
Then, I pre-processed the data collected from home
appliances. I only took the necessary information and went back and forth with China.
Because the source data was not available to me, I
proceeded with the process of mapping each of the information given in the API.
Oh, and meat has various characteristics. When I analyzed the lyrics, I
tried to use the new Google standard, but what?  There is a foreign language version, a version with added remix Fitz pairing,
and a full version, so each song is categorized by filtering from the title.
Next, I'm going to talk about analysis. First of all, when I say keyword analysis, I
change the word view to an open source that derives keywords.  There are a lot of them.
Among them, there was a kr word link, Sohee nlb, and in
conclusion, I chose open source extracted from Kai form for 2 years.
The reason is that when I saw the results of keyword extraction, I thought it was meaningful in the lyrics.
Words are excluded. However, it is true that analyzing all keywords
extracts important keywords from unstructured and very unorganized sentences in movie reviews or reviews, but the lyrics themselves are
short in length and each word is included, so the meaning is implied.  Since I
thought it was organized and organized, I
thought it would be better to classify all the morphemes and extract the keywords I think alternately, without having to do this in the phrase book.
So I selected the Kai word, 1 Kai
morpheme made by Kakao.  It's an analyzer.
First of all, I chose Kai after comparing the results on the Cola NLP site and selected the
appropriate one. The
method was to analyze the morphemes in the new song lyrics and then extract keywords.
Here, I went through the process of extracting keywords.  I added a custom dictionary and
used only Korean.
First of all, I excluded Japanese and also excluded numbers. In fact, English is also
important, but due to the nature of K-pop honorable mention, in this case, there are cases where it is repeated only by adding drinks, so for
now, I used Korean.  First, we conducted keyword analysis.
So, when deriving the result, we classified the result, morpheme, result, word,
keyword, and the criteria were whether the word meaning was achieved and the
frequency.
Then, we used sql to extract the keyword.  I
created SK according to the 12 indicators, and
then
changed the data according to the way to display the data by making an SQL query according to the 12 indicators, and then
went through the process of saving it as a Sys Minha data file. The
extracted results are shown on the left.  You can see that I have organized my columns in the file, and on
the right you
can simply see the results like this. Now,
if I extract the data like this, I
am wondering how I will show the results,
so I will tell you about it.
First of all, there were two images for deriving the results I needed
and showing them. Let's
show the data and then show the storytelling content I thought of.
4 Sheet content doesn't have to be grand; it can be a variety of things like videos, games,
photos, and other things like that.  You can
think of any form of creative work as content, but it is only
considered content if it has value in information or experience.
So, I thought that the way to show these two things appropriately was as
expected. As a general example, I will talk about why it is necessary to see it.
When you visualize data like the one on the left of the indicator data, the word cloud
pin also efficiently shows the main keywords according to the source.
So, I think visualization is the most efficient way to show the core message that the data is trying to show.
Then, I thought, is there no way to make this easily and share it quickly?
There is an existing method that I used.
In fact, there are many different ways to give 4, but I think it depends on the choice.
So, I created the same content as before with HTML tags.
Write a style, then implement this with JavaScript.
Then, you can see that the result of the visualization content is warm as shown on the right.
However, this can only be shared by uploading it, and even if you
take a screenshot, it can be shared on the blog.  Even if you upload a photo, it has the characteristic of being interactive.
So what I was looking for was a service for the purpose of business.
In fact, it is a service that I discovered while studying technology.
Since the content is written in Markdown like lotion, I can easily enter the content name and
upload the file.  The port, which is a library, is the defining characteristic of a server.
After implementing d3 in JavaScript, if you press the play button in the upper right corner, you
will immediately see the old version. Although it is not completely the same as JavaScript, any JavaScript developer can easily create it right away.
So, the result shown.  I thought it was a great advantage to be able to view it right away on the web, change it, and even share it.
And let me tell you a little more about the features. When I was implementing the visualization, there
were times when I was worried about how to implement the visualization.
Object Ball has a gallery and a search function, so
I was able to solve my concerns about what and how to elaborate through various examples. And
since the code was implemented, it was reusable, so it was
very nice that it didn't take long to implement. In
fact, the woodworking method was great.  Mike Moss Talk also talks about this. It is a
very good way to reuse, and it is
more important to learn more easily and take more by sharing like this.
So sharing and learning were very helpful, and I was able to feel myself again.
Esther I  Here, the purpose of sharing spherical content was carried out through a double service.
So, I will show you the spherical object I created.
First of all, my post is not very good, so I will
give it to you one by one based on that.
First, I will talk about the method of classifying data.  I
looked at Bitch's writing about the songs that BTS Elga had made so far, and I was able to see 38 albums and 206 and
226 echoes.
Then, I looked at how many new songs I had marked P in the lyric analysis, and I
can definitely get 161.
Simply put, 0
So, I looked at how much the PTS members participated in the song work. I
was able to see that BTS's participation in composing and writing lyrics was 71% and 72%, respectively.
This can be seen as a rather high proportion, but
looking at the number of participation by year
and the number of members by year,  Even if you look at the number of times each person participates, you can see that they are doing it consistently. The
proportion is high, and if you
look at it like this, you can see it by all members. And
then you can see that among them, the one below is participating the most.
So, this high proportion of people are steadily participating.  In fact, you
may not be able to tell if this is not true,
so I compared other comparison groups.
First of all, I selected
two groups, EXO and GOT7, based on the fact that the other male idol groups that I did not compare debuted at a similar time or had a similar number of members.
First of all, I looked at each classification as before, and I
can see that EXO has the most by hand, followed by BTS, and then GOT7.
So now I looked at each participation level, and there is a light that was not there before at 70%.  You
can see that GOT7 participates at 30% and EXO at less than 10%.
Also, please turn off the number of participation by period between groups. We
can see that BTS is consistently participating in relatively high numbers.
So through this, Light really does participate.
When I compared other boys, I could see that there were a lot of them.
Of course, there is a reason why each idol group has a different agency, so I'm
not talking about this with the intent of competition. I want to tell you about the baby,
so this kind of sincerity and direct eps.  Looking at the proportion of participants,
I know that the Jinjang fight is at a certain level, so let's take a
look at what kind of story there is next and what kind of
story is being conveyed in the lyrics.
And
when you look at the lyrics first, you can see that the part we talk about the most is Detective Van, me,
you, and us.
But of course, this is something we talk about a lot, and because it is so frequent, it is like
this.  This part ended up lowering the frequency of other keywords too much, so I
realized that there were a lot of words like a child, so I tried to
exclude this part and look at other
keywords. So, I looked at the entire word cloud to see what kind of keywords they were used in the lyrics.
Love  Dream Words People of the World
Now I can see that there are these parts, and I can also see many other things. When
I look at it like this, it seems like I'm seeing it all at once, so
I receive keywords by year.
So at the beginning of my debut, my
members came from Jeolla-do, Gyeongsang-do, Chungcheong-do, and Seoul.  There were keywords like this,
and the next year, you
can see that they also talked about the phenomenon of spas, such as dreams and love, and then backbone, Frager padding, etc.
In fact, if you look at up to this point, you can see how many different stories this is, and I dare
not even come up with 2000.  I
couldn't come to a conclusion here, so I made another comparison between other groups. First, I
looked at the keywords based on Takboship frequency. Looking at it like this, you can see that the keywords with high empty tosses for BTS and
other groups are similar.
So, actually, I thought that the keywords that came out like this were Cron,
but when I saw that other groups had similar aspects, I had doubts again, so I
tried to interpret it a little bit as shown below.
So, it was a process of finding a lot of different stories.  I did it one more time and thought
it would be good to look at BTS's own story. So, in
order to see BTS's own story, after removing keywords that were overlapping with sweat and other boys' idols,
1680 6 keywords were extracted. When I
looked at those keywords, they were somewhat similar.  I thought it could be
classified, so I did another classification, and the frequency was based on keywords above the ideal range.
This is a bit of a battle for me, so please
leave a comment if there is anything to improve because it is a bit long.
So, the classification I saw was based on the frequency spec.  In this way,
when you set it to 2 or more, you can see more keywords. When you
set it to 2 or more, I looked at other categories. Among these, there
were two things that caught my attention.
First of all, BTS knows their own stories without being in a hurry.  I
could have said that
I was talking about things like Seoul and Jeolla-do, which I mentioned earlier,
or at the beginning of my debut, I wrote a list of words that teenagers could sympathize with, such as their mobile phone CSAT.
5 I was able to see that the sincerity of direct participation increased, and when
I looked at the second part, I saw how diverse the stories were.
Usually, the stories here are mostly about love, separation, and meeting, but
BTS is about social phenomena.
There were many keywords that could help you understand what kind of social phenomena existed at that time,
and emotionally, it was not about things like love, difficult things, breakups, 7-strings, etc., but
also various categories such as anger, anger, strength, respect, admiration, or hate and hypocrisy.  You
can see that they are talking about a wide spectrum of emotions. And although I didn't do fire fertilizer, it's more like
empty toast, so I'm still 11 If you look at other words, you can see that
5 artists also talk about faith,
um, and food. People on the Han River really often talk about it.  However, you
can see that he said things that were not found in the lyrics.
So, I was able to see these two things I noticed through the data, and
after introducing Won-ah, I finished my personal project.
So I went back and found out what was in BTS' lyrics.  Let me sum it up one more time.
BTS achieved empathy through the
sincerity and wide emotional spectrum that they did not hesitate to call and tell their stories in person,
and
various stories that others did not tell in their lyrics, and
through that, people empathized.  So I
thought that what my project delivers is,
in fact, you can get a feel for these aspects just by listening to the song.
But I
think I did a qualitative and quantitative analysis by looking at the data directly and constructing visualization content. And through that, I think I did a qualitative and quantitative analysis.
p I think it was a process that increased the public's persuasiveness about the comfort and empathy that kisses provide.
Uh, once I finish it, I'll tell you what I'll do after the next project,
and I think I'll continue to
study for G3 steadily at Gusu. Okjeo  By doing law, I fork and translate other people's writings or 0 chic, and I
am also adding dark realism one by one, and
the things I did in the project are easier to secure, or longer sentences. Of course, I also have the
courage to do sentiment analysis and want to see it.
And I'm going to continue to create and create visualization content for this purpose in the future.
This is the end of my presentation. I
don't know how you heard it, but I
also want to say thank you to JS Comp for having a place where I can share it like this.  I hope that
those who are frustrated and having a hard time due to the coronavirus will also find it difficult, so I
hope that we can continue to create an enjoyable experience by sharing it with everyone who is working on personal projects. Thank you